ok es öfters ich probiere in den 90ern
zu leben für 24 stunden beziehungsweise
also viele sachen aus den 90ern zu
machen wie ich halt schaffe in den 24
stunden ich frühstücke jetzt erst mal
und dann steht die erste sache aus dem
tagesplan nämlich vintage shoppen mit
jana und ist somit überreden kamera um
zu laufen
ich musste erst mal fragen ob ich bin da
erregt ist das schon direkt wo es
tatsächlich würde ich dann einfach die
freie hand lassen oder brauchst du input
von mir dann mach einfach was richtig
ist und ich muss dann an finanz tag
alles sieht sie aus durch diese kameras
[Musik]
hast du ja nicht so du hast einen teil
dastehen und dahinter hängen tausend mal
das gleiche nur einzelstücke und deshalb
muss man sich ja durch muss viele
aufmerksam dass du kannst ja von mir bis
jetzt sehen ob die jacke vielleicht beck
trend heute du musst halt alles
ausziehen und so ist alles eine sache
32 weitere shopping beratung mich
gefragt ob ich helfen kann
wenn man euch durch diese kammer hier
anschauen guckt euch jetzt einfach mal
einfach so aussah ist so ein film kostet
noch hinzögen
dankeschön
[Musik]
ich habe eine lange ist auch im sport
oft besonders hervor werden
dieses sports
die socken sind auf jeden fall 1 die
passen
die passen rauskommen muss das oberteil
in die hose stecken euro in 2009
ja also ich glaub ich die hose so
kampfsport und das ambiente nicht die
gefahr dass andere an
ich glaube auch
bradley cooper ist warum was wir warum
du musst du ein bisschen annehmen das
muss man günstige schneiden kann ich
voll
jetzt hab ich das t shirt das andere
anschaulich zuletzt ich glaube auch es
war das was ich wollte
der ist so entertainment zwecken
ja aber das auch mal anfangen anderen an
wie meinst du mit anderen parteien als
auch das motto für die hose seitdem
passiert und welche risiken des mittels
das ist besser als das erste
zufrieden
euro keller die sind groß ich habe einen
riesigen stapel klamotten mit namen wie
werde ich gleich anziehen
melo hat auch noch was gefunden eine
jacke die sie jetzt schon über alles
liebt und es mir sehr gespannt ich die
sachen gleich an habe wie das aussehen
wird
aber es hat viel spaß gemacht jetzt vor
hier soll jetzt für dich selbst jetzt
auch in meiner wohnung was geht jetzt
fühlt sich immer wieder andere zeiten
andere jahrhundert oder was
[Musik]
so wie auch ich praktika bieten und
herzen bei denen beth contini malblock
eigentlich wollte man sagen danke dass
du dich auch für mal wieder eine schöne
erfahrung
deshalb passt es wieder eigentlich folgt
weil es kommt also krass alles wieder
aus den a ligisten deshalb dass ich mir
machen ein video mit einem foul am
donnerstag bietet aber passieren meint
vettel
[Applaus]
dpa
[Musik]
danke nochmal an elo dass sie mir
geholfen hat und mal schauen was meinen
tag in den einst noch so bringt so leute
mein outfit angezogen ich habe noch die
perfekten schuhe dazu gefunden also in
meinem schrank und mache mich jetzt auf
den weg zu sturm weil sturm ihr habt ihr
vielleicht wisst eine retro
spielesammlung das heißt für mich ich
kann vorbei steppen 90er spiele spielen
in meinem outfit und kelly ist anders
das heißt richtig lustig ich gehe zu den
let's go mehrere favoriten filme von dem
weil so ein bisschen was aus der zeit
schon dass ich das kann man vorher das
lied der liebe ist doch rapper der das
will
zumal dieser auch torpediert werde schon
einen ersten blick auf meinen auftritt
überhaupt im review 800
wie konnte das gericht ich das irgendwie
sie ist auch richtig meinte gestartet
ich war bei einem vintage vor
was können wir fahren ins spiel mein
bett natürlich habt ihr angebliches mal
präsentiert ist so perfekt dieser
riesige fernseher und dann einfach die
tapete die bilder ohne willst es war die
perfekte idee hier bei freddy
vorbeizukommen
hier setzen wir uns erzählen und spielen
gegeneinander irgendwelche geld ich weiß
noch gar nicht was aber ich war erst vor
ort gibt euch das brett das man wieder
so aufgewertet gerade das kein spaß
1923 bis 1990 und hört mal
[Musik]
inzwischen konnten
ich schätze an disney film gucken wird
kurzerhand höher springen
nach treffen
übergriffen macht er selbst mehr
genommen müsste dann ein abkommen für
die gar nicht solche bilder die daten
kann zu kommen weil hier und das ist
okay aber ich glaube dass mich das schon
die komplett abgehangen und das mit
wahrscheinlichkeit haben wirklich
wilfried mercks berichtet der ist nicht
den immer in den pigs kein großes
problem
nein ich bin in der wand und in die
nächste wand ich glaube das wird
ich würde mich zukommen keine gegner
dieser strecke geschleudert werden uns
der stimme zu zweit
seitdem ist das thema für die gegenwart
ist relativ eindeutig dass freddy die
sachen gewonnen hat ich mich ob ich
überhaupt eine chance haben the phone
house andere seht ihr dass leute kennst
du das nicht hast du noch nie gespielt
dass man fucking absolutes lieblings
[Musik]
racers sieht gut aus
ja es ist schon richtig krank gewesen
also das war damals als die filme wenn
wir auf erfolgreiche das ist als auch
noch so das ist so
wobei für mich ist es jetzt
glücklicherweise so erreichbar
jakob hat mir die kamera berlin ich kann
ihr befremden die game stocken kommen
und konnte halt auch zum tragen unser an
sich ist es glaube ich gar nicht so
super durch den film wo gange
jung ist es schnell passiert
dazu sagt sp schwer ich bin doch ich
will helfen
es wird schnell noch das wort sagte -
nicht von allen tagen gefahren
okay leute freude hatte ich habe ein
gerät aber da vorne ist er das was ist
hier gerade sagen so ja vielleicht hat
man eine chance ich habe probiert ich
mal 1000 eigentlich will ich gar nicht
weiter stören es war geil hier nur kurz
auch in die spielewelt der 90 jetzt
machen wir etwas anderes
das hier ist der ehrenwerte spender der
vrs kamera jakob auf jeden fall leute es
ist einige zeit vergangen ich habe nicht
so viel leid chinesisches gemacht mein
auto wird natürlich noch gerobbt ihr
wisst was es ist und wie fandest du
jockey und revier wo wir klassisch im
style und 90er einen spieleabend machen
werden
und da nehme ich euch natürlich auch ein
bisserl der neunziger eine neuzugang hat
man zu verschiedenen orten und tageszeit
punkten spieleabend gemacht denn man
konnte sich möglicherweise nicht mit dem
smartphone beschäftigen oder etwa die
unterhaltungselektronik medien irgend
eine katastrophe
erst dann habe ich nur noch die lange
ich sagte zu meinem outfit
nein für die akustischen bitte was
ich mag es eben weiß mag und zu guter
letzt sind in den rhein trieb studios
die deutsche bahn baut eine spur strecke
zwischen köln und mitglied im museum in
münchen gibt es eigentlich nicht ich
hoffe ihr habt genug
nein ich habe wir haben es noch ewig
geschädigte vergleich nach hause fahren
was moralisch gemacht hat wir haben
songs geschrieben und performt und ich
würde sagen ich verabschiede mich
einfach schon mal von diesem tag und wir
sehen uns morgen früh wieder wenn auch
die 24 stunden erreicht sind leute was
geht das ist der nächste tag
ich habe schon eine große aufgabe vor
mir heute und dass diese aufnahmen zu
digitalisieren das wird echt nicht
einfach aber in jedem fall krasse
erfahrung gestern ich bin super froh
dass ich es gemacht habe war wirklich
interessant diese ganze diese ganze
projekt diese ganze erfahrung zu machen
ja ich würde sagen wenn ihr irgendwelche
ideen habt was ich mit der vsg kamera
machen kann was ich in diese richtung
von video nochmal machen kann schreibt
unbedingt in die kommentare
ich würde sagen dann beende ich jetzt
den tag in den 90ern
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
was auch megane als würd ich auch schon
eine krasse idee und bis dahin macht gut
tut